ON BOARD.
ERIC: TURNS OUT THAT TWO NEW
CONTAGIOUS VERSIONS OF
CORONAVIRUS ARE SPREAD AGO CROSS
THE GLOBE, HOSPITALS ON HIGH
ALERT FOR NEW NEW STRAINS, ONE
NEW VARIANT FIRST DETECTED IN
UNITED KINGDOM AND NOW CONFIRMED
IN THE COUNTRY, COLORADO,
CALIFORNIA AND IN FLORIDA.
WHILE A SECOND STRAIN HAS BEEN
FOUND IN SOUTH AFRICA,
FRUSTRATION GROWS OVER
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE ROLLOUT IN
THE COUNTRY EVEN THOUGH IT’S
COMING.
>> THIS IS CERTAINLY THE
EPICENTER, HI, ERIC, NEW YEAR IS
STARTING WITH GROWING CONCERNS
ABOUT THESE HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS
MUTATIONS, ONE OF WHICH EXPERTS
SAY IS LIKELY SPREADING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE BRITISH STRAIN HAS SHOWN UP
IN CALIFORNIA, FLORIDA AND IN
SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA WHERE 3
MEN WHO HAD NO KNOWN CONTACT
WITH EACH OTHER SOMEHOW GOT IT
BRINGING TO FOUR THE NUMBER OF
CASES THERE AND FOLLOWS EARLIER
CASES CONFIRMED IN FLORIDA, MAN
IN 20’s WITH NO RECENT TRAVEL
HISTORY AND IN COLORADO WHERE
THE GOVERNOR SAYS HEALTH
OFFICIAL EXPECT TO CONFIRM A
SECOND CASE SOON AND HE’S NOT
SURPRISED.
>> THERE’S A LOT OF COMMERCE AND
TRAVEL BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES
AND LONDON AND THERE’S NO
SURPRISE THAT IT WAS NOT
ENCAPSULATED THERE.
>> WHILE THE VARIANT IS 70% MORE
INFECTIOUS DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
MORE DEADLY.
OFFICIALS IN SOUTH AFRICA HAVE
CONFIRMED THE FIRST CASE OF
BRAND-NEW STRAIN IN A PERSON
THAT ARRIVED FROM SOUTH KOREA ON
DECEMBER 26TH, SOUTH KOREA
CONFIRMING THEY HAVE A EFFICIENT
SUFFERING FROM THIS BRAND-NEW
VARIANT, DIFFERENT FROM THE
BRITISH ONE.
ALL OF THIS COMING AS MASS
VACCINATION EFFORT CONTINUES TO
SPUTTER ALONG, LONG WAITS IN
FLORIDA THIS WEEK AFTER GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS SAYING ANYONE 65 OR
OLDER COULD GET A VACCINE ON
FIRST-COME, FIRST-SERVE BASIS,
ACROSS THE COUNTRY LOGISTICAL
PROBLEMS HAVE MEANT ONLY
FRACTION OF AVAILABLE DOSES HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN ADMINISTERED.
>> IT REQUIRES STRATEGIC
PLANNING, PREPARATION AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO HAVE FUNDING AND
WITHOUT FUNDING AND REALLY GOOD
STRONG COMMUNICATION, THEN WE
END UP SEEING A DELAY.
WE’VE GOT ABOUT 3 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED BUT WE NEED TO PICK
UP THE PACE BECAUSE THAT WILL
HELP SAVE LIVES.
>> JUST UNDER 3 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE GOTTEN THEIR
SHOT.
21 MILLION AMERICANS LEFT TO GO
IN FIRST VACCINATION PHASE,